now let's dive specifically into this
topic and um what we're going to be
covering today is the motivations for
this some principles that you can adopt
some some patterns that abstract some
best practices and some handsome
examples uh one thing to mention is uh
that
we are going to be exploring this from
the perspective not just of how can we
deploy and monitor a model but how can
we actually enable this monitoring and
more specifically advanced monitoring at
scale with hundreds if not thousands of
machine learning models
so
with that uh as i was mentioning um you
can find you know the blog post with all
of the resources so please do check it
out and if you have any feedback you
know the projects are open source or
you're
able to actually provide any sort of
insights into that
now let's set the scene um we all are
aware that production machine learning
systems are hard you know there's a lot
of specialized hardware that is involved
there's a lot of complex dependency
graphs
there's compliance requirements that go
not just to the same level that
software
environments require but now with the
nuances of machine learning as well as
the
reproducibility nuances that that you
need to have in place so from that
perspective it is important uh to take
into consideration not just how you can
develop and deploy those machine
learning models um to be able to have
them in production but how can you have
more of a a a proactive as opposed to
reactive interaction on the performance
of the model and being able to address
some of the issues that may arise such
as performance drift
as well as
changes in the distribution of the data
of your production models
so the key context to remember
throughout this is that
now it's it's more popular belief
that the life cycle of the model
actually begins
once it's deployed right it doesn't end
when you finish training it is when you
put it in production and it starts being
consumed that the life cycle really
begins uh and you need to make sure that
you have the infrastructure and
capabilities in place in order for you
to um uh have uh the
robust uh requirements uh from a more
proactive perspective the
ability to know when you need to retrain
the model the ability to know when you
have to identify and deep dive into a
specific prediction as well as the
general uh health of the models
themselves
so what we're going to be doing today is
seeing how this applies into a model
specifically we're going to be deploying
a single model as a microservice we're
going to be then able to see how this
deployed model can't expose metrics uh
that could be used for performance for
statistical performance for outlier
detection for drip detection and for
explainability
so what we're going to be doing today is
we're going to be taking the hello world
of machine learning this c510
classification this is basically a model
that takes as an input an image and
predicts one of ten classes in this case
it would be the image of a truck and it
would predict uh you know the last class
which in this case would be a truck
right so this is basically what our
model is going to do given that we focus
on the production
life cycle of the model we're not going
to be training the model from scratch
but the but the code is available if you
want to do it it takes a couple of hours
uh but we're going to be just fetching
this resnet 32 c510 model so it's
basically a tensorflow based model that
we're going to be able to leverage with
python we're going to be
running uh the input being an image and
then the output in this case is going to
be an array showing us that it's the
image the class of a truck
right
the way that we're gonna now
productionize it is using this framework
called zeldan core so seldom core allows
you to convert uh or go from a from an
artifact right so what we just saw a a
model artifact an exported binary like a
pickled binary or a python java or r
code wrapper into a fully fledged
microservice that can be deployed in
kubernetes and
has a set of building blocks that allow
you to actually connect into complex
structures like having multi-arm bandits
outline detectors feature
transformations as part of your separate
reusable components that in themselves
are services right so the way that this
is done is basically taking that
artifact that we had or creating a class
wrapper which in this case is just a
simple python class with a predict
method
once we actually um convert it into a
full container using the source to image
command line interface we're going to
basically have a component a container
that we can deploy and that will expose
a rest grpc and kafka endpoint that will
allow us to be able to you know perform
inference on anything that we send so
whatever goes through this predict
method basically it's passed through the
model and then is returned to us right
very intuitive
now the way that we're able to leverage
seldom core is through the kubernetes
way right defining your configuration
schemas or your manifests in this case
we are able to leverage some of the
prepackaged model servers so in this
case it could be tensorflow serving it
could be triton it could be a
scikit-learn model server but in this
case we're using the tensorflow server
and we're providing that binary as a
google bucket right so what we ended up
doing was just exporting the uh artifact
and then uploading it into google bucket
so that we can then just provide this in
this declarative way into selden so then
seldom is able to uh basically take this
and create the relevant containers
services networking etc so now this
basically becomes a fully fledged
microservice now we are able to see this
as the same inputs that we were running
in our local model we can now run it as
a rest request right so we're sending a
request to a predict method containing
that input image and then our output is
basically that class which is basically
a truck right so we've deployed the
model but again this is where the talk
really starts right because the point of
the talk is deploying the model and then
monitoring it right so what we're going
to now start looking at is
the monitoring pieces which you will be
able to find a lot of relevant examples
if if you're interested to dive deeper
into the seldom correct me this open
source so please go ahead if you find an
issue you know open an issue that's the
beauty of open source so let's actually
have a look at what what is the anatomy
of production machine learning systems
right because the life cycle of a model
starts from data to experimentation to
deployment to monitoring right so the
way that we can abstract it is by able
to see that
a data scientist will be either through
their jupiter notebook or through an etl
uh pipeline they will be converting
training data
into trained model artifacts right this
could be either that binary that we saw
before or uh the container that we saw
before
then the next step is to be able to
productionize it either uh you know
through the
manual
cli or by introducing a ci pipeline that
automatically performs a deployment that
allows us to have those deployed
services which ultimately have inference
data that passes through them right so
any new data that you want to consume
you would pass it through the models but
where are the metrics right so the four
key areas that we're going to be delving
into today uh they're a little bit more
but um these are performance metrics and
tracing so this is the same things that
you would want to monitor for a micro
service um statistical performance so
this is basically model machine learning
specific um
uh metrics that you would want to
monitor drift detection and outlier
detection
for
data that perhaps is uh wanted to be
flagged uh being you know outside of the
distribution in one way or another and
then finally explainability in the
context of production models now another
reminder of the key thing that we said
as a as a premise is that we are
thinking about this not just from the
perspective of how can we have
monitoring for a model for a single
model but we want to ask the questions
of what are the patterns that will allow
us to perform monitoring at scale to
have hundreds of models with perhaps
dozens of advanced monitoring components
because you have to remember that if you
deploy a model and then you add a drift
detector
even though the drift detector is in a
way reducing risk for you to be able to
say well now i have that component to be
able to flag any issues in a way you're
introducing another machine learning
component that equally requires
monitoring in itself right so the drift
component will also be a service that
may fail may um also suffer from the
same challenges that other machine
learning components would suffer from so
it's something to take into
consideration that we will be addressing
as we talk about the different patterns
in a more sort of like higher level uh
perspective so starting with performance
monitoring this is basically analogous
to your machine learning microservice
monitoring so this is monitoring the
performance of your running
service right
this is to identify potential
bottlenecks in performance debug and
diagnose unexpected
performance on that service
and this is really the usual things that
you would imagine like cpu percentage
etc which we will see in a bit the way
that you would see it from a sort of
more abstract perspective is that once
you deploy your model uh one of the
benefits of having this orchestration
tools like seldom core is that not only
it provides you with the end points to
consume but out of the box it exposes
those metrics that can be consumed by
something like prometheus so you know if
your model is suddenly perhaps having a
memory leak you may you may actually
start to see that the uh memory starts
to increase up to a point where it may
crash and then you can actually go and
check
why did that happen similarly you can
actually see some things such as the
performance of the model itself given
that a lot of the work that it's done is
cpu intensive right so if you have
worked with python before you know of
the um
you know of the of the of the uh
infamous uh gill right so from that
perspective it is how you are able to
optimize for the internal configurations
of your model server such as minimizing
in this case the number of threads
making sure that the number of workers
are aligned to the number of cores or
well times two plus one uh and also
making sure that you if you have too
much then it may actually end up with
cpu throttling so there's quite a lot of
things to consider but uh this per this
this monitoring of performance is the
same or analogous to the one that you
would expect to have in microservices
and from that perspective it could be
things like latency uh requests per
second cpu memory uh usage utilization
number of of of successful and failed
requests etc etc so these are equally
important and uh still shouldn't be kind
of like left off in your machine
learning stack the second point is
statistical monitoring so for
statistical monitoring we need to take
into consideration now not just generic
microservice metrics because even though
uh it is still a production uh software
system
we are still dealing with something that
is much more nuanced and in this case
the machine learning components will
also require some further metrics that
are going to be very specialized in this
case it would be um perhaps uh something
that may require
the correct target labels right so in
your training environment when you train
your model you're going to have your
data and your target labels right and
you're going to be able to train a model
because you have all of that data in
there however when you deploy a model
you are not going to have those target
labels right because it's inference data
it's on scene data points and what that
means is that in order for you to be
able to calculate things like accuracy
precision recall uh or other more uh
specific ones like rmsc or
several others you may require having
what we refer to as stateful
metrics right being able to collect
those re uh
annotations that
include the correct target label that
may be provided in an asynchronous way
right so once you deploy a model you
receive some requests you may need
somebody to actually go and re-annotate
those requests
then you will be able to start seeing
some of those uh uh metrics like
accuracy precision recall of course
there are others like kale divergence as
well as perhaps some that you don't
require that feedback or that correct
label but from that perspective it does
open some challenges of how do we
achieve or how do we enable for this
concept of feedback at scale
so the way that we have been able to
address this uh with seldom core is that
similar to how you have a predict
endpoint that performs inference on top
of your model we actually also enable a
feedback endpoint and this feedback
endpoint is able to use the unique
request id that you receive when you
actually send an inference to allow
other individuals to
provide those um
correct labels right so you can do an
inference request you get told okay so
this is request id 55
now somebody else later on can say well
actually i'm going to now submit a uh
correct label for id 55 right so we can
now see that from an architectural
perspective we now are able to abstract
the concept of feedback as part of the
models where the inference request as it
as it comes it gets saved into a in this
case key value store
and when the actual feedback is provided
instead of actually being calculated
inside of the actual microservice
this uh corrected label is actually
forwarded into
any other advanced monitoring components
that want to do something with it in
this case we have a component that just
so happens to be listening to to any
feedback to be able to take that id
fetch the
the the the inference request make the
comparison and update its current uh
status so that you're able to then
expose the specific uh stateful metrics
through this advanced monitoring
component which we name as metric server
now
some of the metrics that are provided
wouldn't be just like the accuracy right
because you may want to actually have
further granularity so that you can
actually get you know things like the
accuracy per class or per sub class you
may want to have to get the the
precision recoil per subclass etc so
from that perspective you may want to
capture the true positives true
negatives false positives false
negatives and individual um you know
prediction probabilities as well as
other things now what what a metric
server looks like in in practice
basically it's another sort of like
abstraction that allows you to basically
take the the truth the response and be
able to calculate those particular
components so from that uh no then you
can see uh the intuition of abstracting
the the the different servers and
services so that you don't actually have
to augment too much into the logic of
your model itself and also to not uh
affect the performance now in regards to
outlier and drift it's similar in
regards to the principles and the core
concepts although detection is to be
able to identify uh you know potential
anomalies in your data and drift is for
being able to identify a divergence in
the data that you are seeing or the
predictions we we are able to use
another of our open source frameworks
called alibi detect which has a broad
range of different uh techniques that
you can actually try out yourself and
more importantly deploy yourself and in
this case we are able to actually show
how we're able to leverage uh an outlier
detector that we train locally following
the same pattern as we did with the
model you train your model locally or
your outlier detector you export it you
deploy it right from this perspective
now we can see that the every single
request that it sends to your model it's
forwarded and it can be captured by any
um advanced monitoring component in this
case it's an outlier detector which is
able to flag whether there's an outlier
or not and similarly for the drip
detection we follow the same pattern in
this case a chaos drift detector we're
able to train it locally and then
deploy it in the same manner such that
it performs the same pattern as the
outlier detector but instead of acting
on a single data point it acts on a
window of data so every let's say 100 or
a thousand of requests it would
calculate that data drift right so
that's basically uh some of the core the
design patterns of the drift detection
um and you know you have to take into
consideration things like scope whether
it's supervised or unsupervised whether
it is a classification or regression
task as well as other things but you can
try all of this in the hands-on code
that we provide
as part of that blog post now the last
component is the explainability piece
and you may have heard about
explainability in the context of you
know jupiter notebooks where you perform
an explanation but now remember that
what we're seeing here is how do we
achieve this at scale how do we enable
these human interpretable insights in a
production environment and we're able to
still leverage the same component uh in
this case is our alibi the explain
library which has a broad range of
different techniques like kernel shop
counter factuals anchors etc all which
can be deployed the only difference is
that similar to how the model receives a
request and returns an inference
response the explainer receives a
request
reverse engineers the model for an
intuition and then returns the actual
explanation right and there are some
nuances to take into consideration how
to choose your exp explainer but again
you know you're able to delve into more
details uh in the repo as well as in the
example this is you know whether your
explanation is local versus global where
it's a white box versus black box this
means whether you actually will need the
artifact of the model as part of the
explainer or whether you can interact
with the separate services as well as
the data type whether it's tabular image
text etc
now from an intuition you know this is
what it would look like from a
microservice perspective you would be
able to actually say well for my model
that predicted that this is a truck what
are the specific reasons why it
predicted that it was a truck in this
case using the anchors explainer it
basically tells you all of the anchors
that made this image at least uh uh the
most sort of like importance to be
predictive rated as a truck
now there is a side note uh about things
that we're not going to cover in this
talk things like adversarial detectors
that are another important thing and are
also covered in the aloe by the tech
library um the actual uh ensemble
patterns that you can also leverage is
something that we're not going to cover
but you can go into too much into more
detail this is basically the ability to
have this architectural patterns
building upon each other right so a
model that has a metric server and a
drive detector that actually acts on top
of the metric server instead of just the
model but you know this is basically
just emphasizing the power that this
architectural patterns provide not just
the abstraction but also the flexibility
that they introduced
so you need to take into consideration
all the things things like alerting you
know what you want to do when drift is
detected defining the service level
objectives or several level indicators
as well as how you feed that into your
promotion strategy and being able to
drill down into any of the results that
you provide but again this would go well
beyond
the scope of this talk
and this the scope of this talk is
already very very large so i think that
is a good point to uh stop on uh today
we covered the motivations for machine
learning monitoring we covered some
principles for some efficient approaches
as well as some scalable patterns that
you can adopt that actually work at
massive scale um as well as the hands-on
example which you can find in uh the
code provided uh with that uh thank you
everybody um and
if there's time for questions i'll be
able to answer if not then we'll be able
to cover them offline
so thank you everybody and yeah i hope
you enjoyed the conference